Um, I was, uh, educated as a chemist.
I did my undergraduate degree in, uh, chemistry
in the University of Science and Technology
of China.
And, around in, uh, 1998, I, uh, went to Howard
to, uh, uh, conduct, uh, research in the chemistry
department to get my PhD degree.
And, uh, 2002, I moved to uni- University
of California at Berkeley, uh, to do my Post
Doc, uh, working on, uh, you know, nanoparticles,
uh, um, materials, electron transport.
2005, I, I joined the Stanford faculty in
Material Science department.
That was the time, in 2005, I started to get
interested in the battery research.
Um, getting into the bat- battery areas in
around 2005 also, that was, uh, around the
time, uh, the, the, uh, uh, renewable energy
become so important.
Clean energy is important.
You know, solar cell research are, are very
high.
So at that time, I, I was already thinking
about, you know, what’s, what’s next.
And after you get the clean energy, you need
to store them.
And, uh, having a car burning gasoline, you,
you want to have a clean energy such as battery
source to, uh, to power the car.
That’s how I get into the battery area in
2005.
Um, my group study very broad topic of research,
including batteries, solar cells, and environmental
technology, and, and the biotechnology, and
also quantum physics.
Uh, I’m really passionate about batteries.
Uh, uh, eh, it, it’s really because it’s
potential, and, uh, uh, and for the society.
I, uh, currently have, uh, two category of
research going in the batteries, uh, areas.
One side is to, uh, produce high energy batteries
for the portable electronics and the, uh,
electrical vehicles through, uh, neo materials
design.
Uh, those, uh, materials can have very high
capacity for storing lithium ions for example.
The second category of research is for finding
neo materials very low cost, very high power,
uh, very high energy efficiency, for the,
uh, stationary, larger scale, uh, uh, storage.
So, um, for, uh, students or for people, you
know, working industry, if they are interesting
in, uh, in the batteries, interesting in material
science part of that, certainly taking this,
uh, battery module will be the, uh, first
right thing to do.
And, uh, reading some of the, uh, uh, uh,
basics about electrochemistry, about the batteries
is, uh, is necessary, you know, to get start.
And then reading about the state of our research.
You know, reading about the past development
of lead-acid batteries, lithium-ion batteries
are, uh, also, uh, uh, absolutely necessary
to, uh, to, uh, get to know what’s happening
in the field.
To develop a source of energy to power everything
in, in my life, that got to be electricity.
Uh, yeah, electricity, you can produce them
clean, you can store them clean, you can use
them clean.
That’s a fun question.
So, how do we survive with absolutely no energy
use?
I think the best way is go to sleep!
[Laughs] Don’t consume energy.